завжди з Великоднім пов'язуєш Надії на
краще надія на нашу перемогу
[оплески]
надію відновлення
і Воскрес цей день ми маємо не тільки
просити в Бога Але дякувати боги за те
що він зберіг твого любив Україну нашу
Україну І що він послав нам сили послав
нам розум для того щоб ми захистилися
від випадіння чужинців і для всіх хочу
привітати і просто побажати що ви до
наступного Великодня була наша
українська перемога от за це ми сьогодні
просимо у Бога і я певний що ці прохання
співпадають з молитвами всіх українців і
всього врешті-решт світу які
[оплески]
хоче щоб ми просто викинули цих
загарбників
нелюдіють
диявола які до нас кинулися а
православна церква України яка була
створена через об'єднання православних
церков і наданням томосу це є церква
українців це є церква Христова і вона
відрізняється від Власне кажучи
Московської церкви втім що у нас церква
є народна у нас церква є Христова у нас
церква є автокефальна а в них церква є
державна і якщо держава в них злочинна
то і зараз уже
ці представники російської православної
церкви в Україні то ми вже
закінчують свій шлях і коли я кажу що
церква українська То це означає що двері
церкви відкриті і для тітки хто нарешті
вам можливість розібратися і
прийти до нашої церкви Я дуже тішуся що
за ці чотири роки майже 5 років вже
тисячі і тисячі парафій приєдналося до
нашої церкви Отже я думаю що це ми це
хотів сказати блаженніший що це є наша
церква наша українська хрестова народна
і саме так і буде Христос воскрес